il régnait aujourd'hui un grand silence
aux abords du collège bienvenue martin
au moment de la récréation et la sortie
des cours aucun bruit
et pour cause sur les 420 élèves que
compte ce collège
il n'y en a que onze qui était présent
aujourd'hui rappelons que depuis début
janvier et bien il y à un des bâtiments
qui est fermée pour des raisons de
sécurité du coup les sixièmes sont
toujours là mais les autres élèves ont
dû être relogés dans un autre collège
d'auxerre dans la tente des travaux et
le problème c'est que le conseil
départemental n'a toujours pas pris de
décision par rapport à ces travaux pour
les parents cette situation ne peut plus
durer alors ce qu'ils ont décidé
aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas envoyer
leurs enfants à l'école
il réclame aujourd'hui des conditions
d'enseignement digne ainsi que
l'installation d'algeco dans les murs du
collège
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que par
solidarité et bien il y à d'autres
établissements qui ont rejoint le
mouvement comme le collège albert camus
qui comptait beaucoup d'absents
aujourd'hui quant au conseil
départemental de l'yonne et bien il se
réunira le 12 avril pour évoquer
l'avenir de bienvenue martin c'est ce
jour là que l'on saura si des travaux
auront lieu ou non